how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the mcu and yesterday in one
division episode 7 we finally
got some reveals and if you haven't seen
one division episode 7 this is your
official spoiler warning we're about to
talk about it but really if you've been
following one division and been
following some of my videos you pretty
much
knew that agnes was agatha harkness it
was fairly obvious and i must have done
about 20 videos where i called her
agatha
but who agatha harkness actually is is
extremely important to what's about to
happen in one division episode
8 and 9 and the future of the mcu
altogether
and right now the fate of wanda
envisions kids billy and tommy are in
the hands of agatha
unless she's already kind of gotten rid
of them which i'll talk about later on
in the video but first let's talk about
who
agatha harkness is why she is extremely
powerful and dangerous
and then we'll talk about what's going
to happen in one division episode 8 and
9.
and talk about her huge connection to
the fantastic four and what it could
mean
for the mcu so if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest one division videos so
agatha's origin story in the comics is
really really interesting because she
was never really a
huge prominent character but she was a
very important character
agatha harkness actually first appeared
in the fantastic four issue number 94.
that's right she was actually a
fantastic four character originally
she was introduced as the governess of
the newborn son of reed richards aka mr
fantastic
and susan storm aka the invisible woman
agatha was the governess of their son
franklin richards now something that's
very
important to note is that franklin
richards would go on to become an omega
level mutant and probably the strongest
character
in the entire marvel universe if not
definitely one of the strongest in one
storyline he
literally uses galactus as his puppet so
reed richards and susan storm were
worried about their baby being safe
because of their dangerous lifestyle in
the fantastic four so they hired her as
a kind of nanny and the protector of him
now in the comics they didn't really
explain how the fantastic four
originally came across agatha the
harness or how they knew her or why they
specifically chose her for the job
but they must have known about her
powers because they entrusted her with
their son
but don't worry later down the road a
little bit more is revealed about her
we find out that agatha harkness is over
10 000 years old she's probably
around 10 500 years old they never
mention a specific birthdate but they do
mention that she was around
500 years before the sinking of atlantis
which as far as marvel comics is
concerned puts her at around 10
500 years old now she was once in a
place called new salem this place was a
safe haven for warlocks and witches
and this place is kind of hidden like
wakanda you have to have magical
abilities to be able to live there
now agatha doesn't end up staying there
she ends up leaving to the mortal world
for a while and we find out that she
actually had a son
named nicholas scratch now nicholas
scratch was kind of the head of new
salem and tricks and convinces the
people there that agatha had committed
treason by leaving new salem and
associating with a fantastic
four who were non-magic wielders and so
what happens is agatha and the fantastic
four end up getting taken
and captured but eventually the
fantastic four were able to free
themselves and then free agatha and so
down the road in 1985 marvel comics ends
up rolling agatha over to the vision and
the scarlet witch story
by this time the avengers comics have
become more popular and agatha is
introduced in the vision and scarlet
witch story as
wanda's mentor and what she really does
is help wanda intensify her powers
so during this time the salem 7 which
was the group that originally kidnapped
her
in the fantastic four run end up coming
back and recapturing agatha now this
time they burn her
at the stake now after this happens
agatha quote unquote
physically dies from this however a
member of the salem 7 named vertigo
ended up obtaining agatha's magical
powers or what you can call her spirit
when she died
but the power was too much for vertigo
to handle and wasn't able to quite fully
control all of this power it was too
much so during this time the scarlet
witch engages in battle with the salem 7
and vertigo loses control of agatha's
powers and wanda
ends up obtaining agatha's spirit and
her powers
and with these powers and being
spiritually coached by agatha
wanda is able to use them and make
herself pregnant eventually leading to
vision and wanda
having kids is this starting to seem
kind of familiar with what we're seeing
in one division
more on that in just a bit now before
agatha vision and wanda didn't really
know how to become pregnant and they
weren't even sure if they could even
have kids together
so it was 100 agatha who was responsible
for wanda and vision
being able to have kids now what ends up
happening is that the twin boys that
wanda and vision have
were obviously magically created and
they end up being the shards of the soul
of the demon mephisto
he is the ruler of the hell realm the
hell dimension not on earth but he ends
up taking the kids back
as they are part of a soul and wanda
kind of like we've seen in one division
starts to lose control of herself and
she gets really depressed and she kind
of becomes insane so agatha
actually wipes her memory of ever having
the twin boys she doesn't remember
them after this now agatha ends up
getting actually resurrected with a
physical body
and eventually the spell that agatha put
on wanda
goes away and wanda remembers her kids
and she's so
infuriated that she goes to agatha and
kills her
now for our sake and wanda vision it's
important to note that years down the
road
marvel did resurrect agatha again and
she continued to coach the scarlet witch
so what's really different from one
division and the comics is that they are
making agatha harkness to be
the main villain it looks like she's
been responsible for everything that has
been happening to wanda
she's responsible for west view and
putting all of these people under her
hex
and agatha took wanda and vision's twin
boys
billy and tommy now she was probably the
one who gave her the kids in the first
place just like in the comics
wanda is surprised that she's pregnant
in episode 2 and since the very first
episode
everything in the reality which we know
was being controlled by agatha was
telling her to have kids and was
stressing the importance of kids so i do
believe it's actually agatha's magic
responsible for getting wanda pregnant
but now of course the big question after
it was revealed that she is in fact
agatha harkness is
why did she want wanda to have kids and
what did she do with them and i don't
think it's very good news for billy and
tommy
now agatha is most likely the sole main
villain for one division
but i do believe that she is actually
going to try and summon the father of
wanda's children the true
father who is most likely the demon
mephisto or some
mcu iteration of him or a combination of
mephisto and nightmare like i've been
saying in my last few videos
mephisto and nightmare both exist in
different dimensions than the main earth
realm and since agatha is clearly evil
and she has
the darkhold book which is an extremely
ancient and evil book created by an
evil god chathan she is most likely
trying to summon
something very evil to this realm which
i believe is going to be
one of the next big bads that we see in
phase 4 phase 5
and all the phases moving forward one
thing to note is that agatha's rabbit
is named senior scratchy now this could
very well just be an easter egg to her
son
nicholas scratch as i mentioned in the
beginning of the video or he could
actually be the one that she is trying
to summon and get into this realm
because in the comics once he's defeated
he gets banished to a different
dimension but he ends up coming back
now we didn't see billy or tommy in
agatha's lair
and they did show a pretty decent amount
of her lair
so they could be gone but i think that
marvel would like to show agatha trying
to summon a huge villain so
maybe they're still alive and maybe
there's a chance for wanda and vision to
save them
especially with the help of photon now
at the end of episode 7
agatha showed wanda what she's been
doing the entire time but i also think
that she took
wanda under her control and i think a
part of this is going to be
wiping her memory just like she does in
the comics she's going to wipe her
memory of the twins
i believe we'll see this in episode 8
but guess who has the power to
awaken people her good old husband
vision who is currently
on his way to go find wanda and once he
awakens her i think that's when we're in
for a very
very big battle at the end between
agatha harkness vision
wanda and photon i believe quicksilver
will be in there somewhere however i'm
not really sure if he
is indeed the actual quicksilver just
under her spell or if he's actually some
evil version
either way paul bettany said that
there's going to be a huge
final battle involving a lot of cgi
and action and this is what's going to
start happening in episode 8
and then in the finale and maybe even in
the post-credits scene we're going to
see agatha
actually summon this major villain and
that's when doctor strange is going to
get involved because she summoned an
ancient
mystical demon and that's how one
division is going to lead up to doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
so now that you know who agatha harkness
is what do you think about the big
reveal and her being the main villain of
one division
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest one division
videos and
let me know how excited you are for the
final two episodes in the comments down
below
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you